tommy larry and tommy look the people of
california going to that poor ucla grad
student who was murdered they vote for
leftists that create policies that allow
things like this to happen when are the
people of california going to wake up
and stop voting in these people
well listen todd every bad idea of at
least the last five years has originated
in either california or new york and
that's no coincidence those two states
also provide a perfect example of what
happens when you allow one party
democrat rule and it's a case study in a
cautionary tale and it's especially when
you look at the lawlessness and the soft
on crime soft on criminals soft on thug
policies that are formed and fomented in
both those states you know i lived in
california for several years and i saw
this firsthand i decided to leave the
state when i realized that some of its
residents seemed more startled by seeing
a conservative like myself in the flesh
than they were seeing an addict light up
a pipe in a yogurt land i also saw that
firsthand but as you said todd if the
people of california and new york want
to make changes they have to start with
the way that they vote nothing is going
to change until you decide to vote for
either moderate democrats who believe in
law and order and protecting decent
people or you vote for republicans that
i know are certainly about law and order
and protecting and preserving the rights
of law-abiding americans in their cities
in their states but they're going to
have to make big changes they also have
an opportunity in both those states to
be a case study of what happens when you
change your vote and you make big
changes to not only your politicians but
your felon coddling policies something
needs to change before it's too late
these numbers tommy are astounding la
crime from 2019 to 2021 homicides up
almost 54
shooting victims up 54
and i think we both know the area where
this ucla grad was murdered it's a nice
area it's the fairfax district i used to
live right around the corner i always
felt safe i was there for four and four
and a half years should anybody feel
safe in a blue city going forward
i think that this is also where you're
going to start to see some big changes
it's one thing when this impacts the
ghettos and the inner cities it's
another thing what impacts nice areas
and that's sad to say because that
shouldn't be the case every american
should be safe on their cities in their
cities and on their streets but that's
not the case in places like california
and i think the democrats and especially
these activist da's need to be asked
what is your motivation for being soft
on criminals and soft on crime what is
it why are you motivated to protect the
lowest denominator of human being in
your cities in your states and why are
you not protecting the law-abiding
americans that look to government for
nothing else but protection democrats
need to answer for that they're going to
have to answer for it in midterms i wish
it didn't take an election cycle to make
big changes but unfortunately sometimes
it does we have a big opportunity to
make big changes and that comes in
november
speaking of not really a change but
going back to the past a former top
advisor to bill clinton says there's a
good chance hillary will run in 2024 if
joe biden loses congress in the midterms
queue up dick mars
hillary has set up a brilliant brilliant
strategy she has set up a zero-sum game
with him
the higher he the worse he does the
better she does
because she's positioned herself as the
democratic alternative to buy him
not just to biden but to the extreme
rest in the democratic party
tommy how bad have things become that
the democrats have to turn to hillary
hillary clinton as their savior
you almost have to feel badly for the
democrat party because that is what
their bench entails someone that they
see as a really a beacon of hope and
change is a two-time loser hillary
clinton who couldn't beat donald trump
whose policies couldn't beat donald
trump the american people don't see
hillary clinton as an alternative to joe
biden they see someone like a donald
trump or ron desantis as an alternative
to joe biden and of course hillary
clinton but the fact that the democrats
think that they should resurrect
hillary's dead political career and
somehow she's going to be the savior for
their party also shows how tone deaf
they are about the actual will and want
of the american people we want america
first policies we want to feel safe in
our cities in our streets and at our
southern border hillary clinton is not
going to be the woman to do that but it
also goes to show when you have a
president like joe biden and a vice
president like kamala harris who are so
so poorly liked and hillary clinton is
your next in line oh boy you guys got to
go back to the drawing board and maybe
come up with something new for a change
nobody is a worse bench compared to the
democrats then of course my new york
football giants don't forget to check
out the final thoughts with tommy
available exclusively on fox nation
tommy thank you hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now